So, like we've done a couple of times before, let's start off by going through
the terms one by one to see if any of them are like terms. X squared right here,
is the only terms with an x squared in it. And negative y squared over here is
also the only term with a y squared in it. However we have these two middle
terms that each have an x to the first and a y to the first. In them.
So, are they like terms. Well, according to our rules up here, they do have the
same variables, and those two variables, x and y have the same power. The x here
is x to the first, as is the x here, and the y here is y to the first, as is the
y here. So presumably they are like terms. What we need to do is use the
commutative property of multiplication, that we talked about a long time ago, to
make these look the same. We know from the commutative property of
multiplication that x times y or just xy is equal to y times x or just yx. So
I'm going to rewrite this term right here, 7yx as 7xy instead. It's amazing how
switching around the orders of factors within terms can change the way an entire
expression looks. Now our job is pretty standard. The terms that we're not
combining I'm just going to write as they are, so x squared is the same. And
then I'm going to combine these two terms in the middle. So remember we add
their coefficients. 3 plus negative 7, or 3 minus 7 which is negative 4 times
the variables x and y minus y squared which doesn't change